لبعض اتهم كانه تحول تتعاون معه او تعمل
معه اغنيه حتى تلحق او تستفيد بالتراند
لخالكوا محمد هالايام
[موسيقى]
كل الناس انا مش محتاج محمد عشان اطلع
تريند عليه انا البس وابقى شكل ابويا كده
اطلع الترند انا ابن شعبان عبد الرحيم واي
وقت هالبس هدوم الجزمه والحزام والبنطلون
والساعتين والحاجات هابقى ترند في ساعتها
انا مش محتاجه اطلع التريند انا محمد انا
محتاج اما لقيت محمد لقيته غلبان قلت
سبحان الله
الدارجه دي كلها لو بتتعمل بفلوس كان
زمانك كلفت 20 مليون جنيه
الدقه بتاعه محمد دي لو بتعمل فلوس كانت
رقم كبير قوي
في ناس كثير قوي بتوع المهرجانات دول
مشهورين قوي وما بيعرفوش يغنون
بدعم المفرط لمحمد عامل النظافه كيف ترد
على ذلك
[موسيقى]
ربنا بعثه له ده رزق ربنا بعثهوله عشان
يطلع من يطلع من الموضوع اللي هو فيه ده